the most famous face in British politics
Boris Johnson defied political gravity
Then Came Crashing back to Earth
this week is six months since he was
forced to leave number 10. I want you to
know how sad I am to be giving up the
best job in the world but then's the
breaks in resignation he promised the
nation there were good times ahead even
if things can sometimes seem dark now
our future together is golden for him it
certainly has been
[Music]
at the start of this year Sky News
launched the Westminster accounts
together with Partners tortoise media
we've built a database to give you at
home unparalleled access to who gives
and who gets the money flowing through
our political system this list here is
the leaderboard of which MPS have
declared the highest earnings in this
Parliament up to the end of last year
now you'll recognize that from January
when we launched the Westminster account
these were the numbers that you could
see back then for the first time then
Theresa May was comfortably top of the
leaderboard earning two and a half
million pounds
but no more now we can show you when
that leaderboard is brought up to date a
new name at the top and frankly it's not
even close nearly 5 million pounds in
earnings for Boris Johnson almost all of
that earned in these six short months
since he departed Downing Street
we can see that near total dominance in
this leaderboard by conservative 17 at
the top 20 here atori blue
and 22 million pounds is the total
amount of money all 650 MPS have
declared on top of their 84 000 pound a
year salary since the last election in
December 2019.
so what's changed since we launched our
Westminster accounts project here
are the MPS who registered the most in
outside income so far in 2023. we've got
the data for just under two months of
earnings today so understandably many of
these numbers are relatively small but
the two men at the top are having an
excellent 2023 financially at least the
second highest earner the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock he's registered
nearly 380
000 pounds so far this year now most of
that cash has come from ITV from his
appearance on I'm a celebrity which saw
him get the nation talking lose the
conservative party whip eat a camel's
private part and earn 320
000 pounds his spokesman told Sky News
that he's donated ten thousand pounds of
that to Charities that three percent of
the total and on top he's added 48 000
pound for the serialization of his book
it's reportedly sold just 3 000 copies
in the first week and his Ghost Writer
isabelout shot has handed a hundred
thousand of his WhatsApp messages to a
national newspaper
all of that relatively small change
compared to the man who's earned far
more than anyone else in this Parliament
this year over 3.7 million pounds he's
been paid over 500 000 pounds by
publisher harpercollins for a book yet
to be published and nearly two and a
half million pounds from an agency which
the former prime minister describes as
an advance for speaking engagements the
sheer scale of Boris Johnson's earnings
really are rather extraordinary look at
this 4.4 million pounds is the total sum
of outside earnings made by all 650 MPS
so far in 2023 and of that figure Boris
Johnson alone has earned almost 85 of
the cash
huge earnings from diverse sources a
speech at the International Symposium on
blockchain advancements in Singapore
earned Mr Johnson over a quarter of a
million pounds Cutting Edge Tech
familiar Johnson material remember
Humanity has been paranoid about this
ever since the Titan Prometheus gave us
the first living flame which you
remember he concealed for some reason in
a tube of of a fennel flower
the highly paid speaking gigs have
spanned Singapore New York and Mumbai
and now Westminster last week Boris
Johnson hosted his first wide-ranging
keynote speech in the UK since stepping
down as prime minister he didn't do so
there in the houses of Parliament even
though they were debating his 2019
brexit deal they did so here at a
conference on global software power
hosted by The Firm brand Finance his
closest allies making the short trip
from Parliament to hear what he says why
on Earth are we having to come to this
event to hear what Boris Johnson thinks
were you here on your son my name maybe
but why here why isn't why is he not
doing it he's got to say if you're here
yeah why is he doing it here and not in
Parliament
the money
no he's going to stop the reciting the
song of the Oompa Loompas about Augustus
Boris Johnson missed the Parliamentary
debate on British sumac's brexit deal
his first public reaction just happened
to be on a very lucrative platform
Boris Johnson how much are they paying
you to pronounce at the brand Finance
conference why aren't you doing this in
Parliament the man who brought Mr
Johnson here
clearly he's my he's my guy
a lot of people hate him I I told lots
of my friends we had Boris speaking and
they all grown and said oh well I'm not
coming then but then you talk to other
people and they said oh that's fantastic
I'm definitely coming you know he really
divides opinion and and that's the good
thing if you have someone who's black
it's boring and I think it was you
making a joke on stage about him needing
to make some money as well presumably he
had to write quite a big check to get
him here today uh I couldn't possibly
comment on that one but yeah it
yes I mean he commands hundreds of
thousands of pounds for organizations
that's a lot to say yes
and you're you think the benefit is
worth it for having him here well he's
certainly worth
um it's like a rock star I mean you pay
them to appear at a concert because
everybody's gonna live stream and
everyone said listen to it he's like a
rock star in political so there's no
doubt about it
[Music]
in Uxbridge rock stars look a little
different here in the suburbs of West
London is where Boris Johnson has made
his political home this is not a safe
seat some constituents far from Happy do
you think he should stand again and if
you if he did would you vote for him
um no I don't think I'd vote for him
again
um he's making a lot of money like you
say doing other things so yeah step down
because you can't do two jobs like that
you know you can't be expected to earn
all that money and then come and help
your constituents no
no step down
I'm okay with that but I wanted him to
focus more on his constituency I'm here
working six days a week but I never see
him yeah I mean I said fair enough when
he leaves office into what he likes you
know but he's he's supposed to be the MP
for oxygen southwester but he's never
here is he
slong out of office by his own party
who'd lost faith in his ability to
uphold standards none of that appears to
have dented Boris Johnson's earning
power but is this the golden future he
dreamed of